oh yes I go him welcome and it's a
revenge killers well stay away from
experiment we don't know Adam and James
baby bok City yo game yo games I don't
little jamesburg video games yeah hello
and welcome to playstation grenade once
again we are here in GTA 5 we have
another let's play for you it's my name
is Adam and as always I'm joined by this
handsome chap James hello have you ever
seen the film Tron James I haven't but I
have seen the future which apparently is
neon neon yes it is indeed well Tron
Tron I think he might like 1982 and
basically it was about jeff bridges to
get sucked into a digital world and he
has to take himself on a digital version
of himself using motorbikes which have
like a tail coming out the back which
are used to destroy all the people this
is the worst description I could ever
imagine that sounds just like my real
life yeah what--right what your tail
keeps popping off let's not do that
right okay so what we're going to do we
are going to take on each over today in
the tron challenge and we'll see if this
DLC is worth downloading some good fella
yeah sounds great and what's it actually
called again it's called deadline it's
that a Tron reference I'll never know
I've never seen it Jim's before we go
into the world of tron on deadline we
need to look the part so we've come to
suburban to look at the different new
outfits which one takes your fancy dude
i'm blue da ba dee da ba die well I like
the pink we've already decided the pink
one is very nice very sensual oh I do
like the pink I've always loved a bit
pink it's not a brown one which would
really suit you but oh well what are you
trying to say i'm going to pick the
orange one for our first race and we'll
see how things go okay dude let's go
into the world of tron oh haha i'm
driving a massive Satsuma
I can see you but you bought some pink I
just tried to take me out so it seems
like you kill them mostly by chance Oh
turn mom oh I managed to get out of that
did you oh I got someone else then and
you got the pinky oh ok this speed
boosts I've only just noticed i can get
a speed boost oh bloody hell fire that
was my speed boost saved it for you oh I
yo-yo string you're still winning though
cool for you yeah I commit suicide so if
you stick a guy edge no I just stopped
come on you must be getting hit there
yeah let's do the world good did it do
there's something going wrong there
right it's it's all tied 4313 voice 29
seconds to go Oh today I was so I was
Sean about to celebrate that I thought I
had you on a doctor now you idiot oh my
god I'm again lasted 12 seconds to kill
ya I'm just trying to escape come on
Helen oh no I just fell off oh no I fell
off I fell off does that mean you're
hydrant do you win I luhan's Iran wins
loser hahaha come on orange strong man
lutron ok Jimmy bum jimmy blue tron
why my life another dude hey little guy
it must be dead yeah thank you actually
rammed into him go no you're I'm you
nearly this is maize I'm gonna stay away
from you oh whoa that was close Oh
petrifying hey we do months oh no wait
you deserved that UT quis at you so
close to killed me that was not very
much I got if we try and get him only
comes down the ramp I know he's got me
oh my god that was scary cotton yeah yes
right it's down to me and you the game
is on do this see how that was high on
mine get bed I was in front of you on
mine ya been I used to speed boost oh oh
oh oh yes no way I bunny hopped over it
you can bunny hop there you go haha that
was the 16 seconds yeah I would have to
just try and drive into him see what
happens so this again was just to round
sirs to know yeah is it just to know
yeah okay yeah what is the first thing
you've ever would what's going on this
is good game this isn't it no this one
looks interesting always head straight
for each other oh right one of these
guys is ahead of us so we need yes I got
it
Jim James so if I activate the slow time
thing does it for every for everyone
yeah oh oh how did he get this yeah I
think we're gonna need a new sound
effect to censor this one oh yeah yeah
oh you're winning now oh great guy great
guy got energy game oh she's me and you
wait yet where are you doing oh no get
you no oh no oh no oh yeah champion Oh
James what are you doing mine away from
you I drove away for you to be nice and
he took me out with friendship is off
I'm gonna check out pink haha you got
all three of us in one go dem skills I
think you'll find I'm gonna boy dad yeah
he's gone de please don't the place go
under eyes no no no yeah it looked just
like a bridge oh I turned away oh my god
it actually made sparks on the side of
my bike I was right in front of you that
was to win wasn't a time it was
your fridge is that enough net die then
dinah dinah diamond yeah whose oh it's
22 is 22 let's get this orange orange
right on it have you noticed I only
suggest we team up when I'm losing when
you lose him please always trying to be
yah yah yah has it got me it's got your
number uh yes oh no I just got myself in
an infinite loop I don't get myself oh
right always stood slow-mo the cheeky
tweet oh yes I jumped over him uh was
happy with that um stuck in the middle
with you were you going that guy's just
killed himself I think yep playing this
with one life it's a scary scary ever I
want that our lan ma I'm sick of helping
you I'm never helping you again oh yes I
going well dumb and it's a revenge
killers well stay away from me
experiment we don't know I didn't know
what to do what drove as wide as I could
hey you can't marry you killed me there
you killed me you've got one life Adam
oh god it's like real life right okay
11 30 seconds to go you can do this oh
no he's coming for you oh we're right by
each other I know I'm sorry I had to
take him out when you were that you got
both of us yeah ah nice one watch out
pattern done we smashed into each other
nah I'm [ __ ] around okay yeah yeah
thank you can again lovely would still
love to but no other game or GTA so far
has inspired screams of agony oh I just
went under my own Luke I love this limo
out of that go right give me a gap give
me a gap okay yeah I got no Road I got a
little road to go around I'm dead
anybody die cuz I need your thing to
blow up ah died yes I think I've got him
here only got me haha think I've got him
he's turning right on himself yeah I had
to back backup of myself then so there
yeah yes oh you're gonna win as well ah
five seconds just stay alive you did on
purpose you mother you come here you
yeah I one of you again Jim's I really
enjoyed playing that game I've loved
going back to the 80's what do you think
of it dude I loved it too but it made me
a little bit emotional and I'm feeling a
little bit suicidal to be honest with
you oh understandable that's why we've
come to the pH you just look out on the
ocean and think about what we could have
done with our lives instead of play
games on youtube I think my last will
and testament will be that everyone
watching this likes and subscribes oh I
like that I'm gonna have that on my
epitaph you know thanks for watching
please do should remove it please
remember to like and subscribe all the
field hahaha I didn't ever see with this
deep this is taking forever this is just
slower with you see you next time I cost
me a banking bomb and please remember
everyone that our last well it is that I
have this up again you've got a lot of
editing to do ya get we are